la page politique de ce 21 novembre avec
grégory est resté bonsoir responsable
ump sur la ville de maurepas vous êtes
venus ce soir en plateau pour évoquer la
création de maurepas 2014 en est le
président fondateur et c'est un groupe
qui se veut en revanche apolitique un
groupe de réflexion avant de se lancer
un tout de même dans la bataille des
municipales en 2014
ça c'est le but avoué je rappelle que la
ville de maurepas est détenu par georges
mougeot socialiste devenu divers gauche
depuis 1989 alors même si votre groupe
est apolitique
on va pas me passer à côté du
rebondissement au sein de l'ump puisque
vous êtes le responsable sur la ville de
maurepas françois fillon qui dans
l'après-midi conteste les résultats
pour lui trois fédération d'outre-mer
ont été oubliées et le ferait passer en
tête avec 26 voix d'avancé il serait
donc le président des recours devait
être déposée certains demandent à
présent à alain juppé de prendre la tête
de l'ump en attendant pour assurer la
transition avec les différentes
commissions statue sur ses difficultés
un nouveau rebondissement énième
rebondissement votre avis votre réaction
en tant que militants et responsables
ump sur la commune de maurepas alors
écoutez j'ai appris en même temps que
vous cette nouvelle je pensais que
cette partie en tout cas de l'élection
interne était terminée apparemment non
donc je n'en sais pas plus je pense
qu'il faut laisser maintenant travailler
la commission de contrôle qui
apparemment a été saisie et puis ensuite
vous êtes déçu par l'attitude de chacun
au sein de l'ump on peut citer parce
qu'ensuite après ses déclarations il ya
eu des échanges notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est devenu très à la
mode
david xavier weiss le secrétaire
national de l'ump quittent en charge des
médias soutien de copé qui traite fillon
de l'ach de pleutres sur twitter
concernant valérie pécresse chef de file
d'ailleurs de l'ump dans le département
des yvelines il lui demande via les
réseaux sociaux tu ne comprends pas le
concept de perdre ton mauvais score aux
régionales ne t'a pas permis de te
remettre en question pour
l'interrogation c'est difficile les mots
certains jours c'est très tendu au sein
de l'uem absolument que je ne partage
pas servir aux échanges je pense qu'il
faut en tout cas appelé à l'unité et au
rassemblement ça ne sert absolument rien
en tout cas aux yeux des français de
laver son linge sale en public et donc à
partir de là il faut se remettre
voilà la commission de contrôle qui
rendra un jugement est ensuite voilà ils
seront faudra tous être unis en tout cas
de derrière le président de l'ump
c'est un coup dur pour les municipales
pour 2014 d'avoir déjà silva nous laisse
déchiré si l'ump réussi à survivre aussi
à ce qui ce matin absolument rien à voir
parce que les français feront la
différence en tout cas entre une
élection interne qui concerne des
militants et une élection locale qui
elle est portée sur celles et ceux qui
font la vie de tous les jours dans leur
commune et du projet qui sera porté si
haut si l'objectif c'est difficile de
porter un projet de représenter aussi
une formation politique si au sein même
de la famille politique et ça ça fait ça
fait voilà je pense que nos d'ici deux
semaines tout sera terminé et l'élection
municipale et dans un an et demi
donc je pense qu'on aura le temps d'en
reparler d'ici là et je pense que tout
sera tout le monde sera rangé derrière
président de l'ump on vient justement au
groupe que vous avez fondé gros félin
apolitique même si vous êtes donc de
l'ump vous êtes 5 au sein de ce groupe
d'où viennent les autres membres
justement de quelle à la ration elles
nous sont eux aussi en politique alors
absolument donc nous avons cinq membres
qui ont fondé ce club
maurepas 2014 qui est un club de
réflexion donc je peux vous les citer il
ya erwan le gall
il ya sandrine faucheux laurent burson
vous avez également
nathalie bellegarde ils viennent de
différentes formations absolument de
sensibilités politiques et même aussi au
sein de la société civile et l'objectif
vraiment de ce club c'est un club de
réflexion comme ces listes ailleurs
comme l'ifrap qui qui débat sur comment
améliorer la
l'état est en tout cas baisser les
dépenses publiques vous avez l'institut
montaigne
vous avez également terra nova est tout
tout tout ces clubs de réflexion sont là
pour apporter en tout cas des éléments
au delà du clivage partisan auquel nous
nous ne souhaitons pas en tout cas pas
retenir pour proposer un projet omertà
bien mais c'est ensuite un début pour
constituer une liste pour les élections
municipales
alors on palabre justement leur raconte
si ça ça pas du tout on en est pas du
tout là en fait ce club de réflexion va
se composer en trois phases
vous avez déjà la phase de réflexion ou
en fait nous allons réunir l'ensemble
des maurepas siens qui font l'effort qui
sont les forces vives de la commune un
exemple lundi prochain nous allons
commencer notre première réunion
thématique sur le monde associatif et ce
monde associatif a beaucoup de choses à
nous dire et on n'a pas besoin de faire
partie d'un parti politique
bien bien bien implanté pour pouvoir
parler de ce qu'est le monde associatif
donc en fait on a invité tous les
présidents d'associations qu'ils soient
de l'association culturelle sportive
sociale humanitaire et on va échanger
sur leur vécu sur leurs expériences et
au travers de ça nous allons faire des
propositions
ces propositions seront écrites dans un
livre blanc un livre blanc communal qui
sera publié ensuite et après chacun
pourra ce sera un petit peu une base
pour un programme également ce livre
blanc ensuite car c'est pour ça c'est le
premier temps ensuite le temps politique
ou en tout cas les candidats déclarés
pour reprendre des propositions qu'ils
souhaitent c'est la phase politique et
ensuite on a la phase post élection
c'est à dire que nous allons instaurer
une espèce de conseil de surveillance ou
de suivi pour savoir si les propositions
que nous avons fait avec l'ensemble dé
mort passe bien parce que l'objectif
c'est vraiment de rassembler autour d'un
projet fou
orateur informatif dire aucun pouvoir
pour ce conseil de surveillance oui
absolument
oui parce que ce club va continuer il va
continuer parce que la france change le
monde change et maurepas change aussi et
donc les propositions qui ont été faites
un moment donné va vont continuer
d'évoluer au sein de ce club de
réflexion
donc c'est pour ça qu'il va perdurer
pendant pendant que pendant des années
on sera candidat en 2014
à la question n'est pas encore là
finalement c'est qu'on peut on peut y
penser et tout le monde y pense à
maurepas
mais là quand les habitants de la ville
de maurepas seront pas candidats aux
élections je suis d'accord je le
souhaite ses dents ça va être compliqué
pour vous aviez bien sûr mais on est
déjà c'est vraiment 2d dans un débat de
réflexion et je pense que beaucoup de
gens inverse il ya déjà les personnes et
le projet nous on fait vraiment le
contraire c'est déjà de penser au projet
et ensuite le temps des personnes
viendra pour le moment donné pas là à la
politique de la ville menée actuellement
voulait reproché quoi bon choix qui sont
pris par le meilleur actuellement
jargeau abaya certain nombre de points
alors là évidemment je change de
casquette puisque là c'est plus dans le
cadre du club mais néanmoins dans le
cadre du club
ceci dit vous montez club pour en faire
remonter des doléances écouter le monde
associatif
ça c'est le travail des municipalités
comme les associatifs est ce qu'on va
faire aussi des réunions sur la sécurité
sur l'éducation et c'est aussi le rôle
d'une municipalité au quotidien donc ça
veut dire que si les gens viennent vous
voir montrent des problèmes des
problématiques qu'ils subissent au
quotidien ça veut dire qu'ils ne
trouvent pas écho auprès du maire
peut-être en tout cas ils n'ont pas le
sentiment que pas fort pas forcément on
est on n'est vraiment pas dans une
démarche partisans tu sais on est
vraiment dans une démarche de
rassemblement d'écouter celles et ceux
qui font la vie ne mord pas de tous les
jours parce que on pense qu'un projet
municipal ne doit pas se faire au sein
d'un clan ou en tout cas au sein d'un
groupe qui ont les mêmes convictions il
faut élargir parce que nous mêmes nous
avons des cursus universitaires
différents nous venons de monde
professionnel différent et à ce titre
nous avons nous n'avons pas forcément
les mêmes
j'irai les mêmes les mêmes idées en tout
cas les les mêmes attentes que des gens
qui pratiquent au quotidien dans leur
domaine nous sommes tout de même allé
demander à quelques habitants de cette
commune de maurepas au cours de la
journée
parce qu'il pensait de la politique
menée actuellement sur la ville ce sont
quelques témoignages que nous avons
recueillis et je le précise seulement
quelques témoignages n'est pas bien
évidemment un sondage sur l'ensemble de
l'opinion de la ville puis c'est bien
ils ont fait des vents faire des
logements président julien c'est bien
moi j'aime ce quartier les crânes mais
un pour les jeunes ouais plus de
logements surtout plus de logements et a
pas grand chose à dire à part qui
achètent un quartier qui sont un peu
délaissé mois-ci immigrés celui-là on
dépose de maisons n'avaient pas trouvé
donc je suis dans le cdi on est là on
trouve six mois dans le département soit
118 il donne pas la maison c'est ça
notre souci je connais pas trop leur
politique justement plus d'espoir sur
lot où on pourrait être tranquilles eux
sont sans embêter les maisons ou les
habitants ce qu'apparemment ou conduire
à chaque fois un gars un peu les autres
il ya des jolies choses mais enfin ça se
fait petit à petit du compte tenu des
contraintes financières pour se plaindre
faut pas se plaindre
c'est ce qu'on entend dans les
différents mais nos trottoirs les gens
sont plutôt héros de regarder mais moi
même ça fait 30 ans que j'habite à
maurepas j'en suis pas malheureux sauf
qu'il ya des choses qu'on peut améliorer
mais justement la vie de ces mauriciens
très intéressant c'est pour ça qu'on
veut créer ce club de réflexion c'est de
recueillir vraiment l'ensemble des avis
des habitants de ceux qui font la vie ne
mord pas dans les différentes
thématiques municipal qui existe et de
se nourrir de sa donc en fait on va
faire un certain nombre de propositions
des propositions quand on nourrit ou
travers des échanges qu'on aura eu avec
toutes les personnalités dans différents
domaines
et puis après voilà en espérant que
qu'elle soit reprise c'est très positif
parce qu'il ne se passait donc ensuite
il y aura le temps politique vous l'avez
dit qu'il sera candidat qui ne sera pas
candidat nous avons contacté georges
mougin qui nous a dit ne pas s'être
encore décidé en tout cas ce n'est pas
très clair même si haut du côté du ps il
se murmure qu'il ne devrait pas se
représenter on évoque plutôt une
candidature socialiste pour ismaël
havane le conseiller général de ce
canton
vous préférez avoir quel adversaire
parce que j'ai pas mentionner aussi
pierre leguérinel qui ancien responsable
du modem aujourd'hui à lui d ea qui est
le premier adjoint également de georges
mougeot le coût du quai d'orsay moment
il n'y a pas encore de candidat en tout
cas à l'ump
donc on est dans une démarche total sera
décidé à quel moment pour le mpc en
meurent pas justement vous êtes
responsable de la section de courant de
l'année 2013 ce sera ce sera tranché
après pour savoir ce qui est de tel ou
tel adversaire pour moment ce peu
importe on est vraiment dans une phase
de réflexion
on n'est pas dans un débat de personnes
et je pense qu'il faut bien mettre cette
idée au centre de
de la réflexion municipale en tout cas
et c'est ce qui intéresse les mots
rasions réflexion concertation
consultation prochaines dates vous
l'avais dit dès la semaine prochaine
lundi 26 on a notre première réunion sur
le monde associatif
ensuite il y aura d'autres réunions se
passera cette réunion justement à se
passera à la maison de sologne à
maurepas
nous avons déjà et reçu pas mal de
réponses en tout cas de gens qui
viendront et c'est très positif parce
qu'on s'aperçoit finalement les gens ont
besoin de parler
ils ont ils ont des choses à dire sur
sur le sur leur sur leur expérience et
ce club de réflexion je le répète c'est
un laboratoire d'idées et des changes et
c'est très positif pour pour pour la
commune et d'ailleurs on nous l'a fait
savoir puisqu'il ya d'autres communes
aux alentours qui nous ont contactés
pour savoir comment on avait pensé
inviter le maire actuel georges mougeot
à venir y participer mais c'est pourquoi
pas mais pourquoi pas sérieusement on va
même invité des élus de la majorité
actuelle parce que chacun à son niveau a
des choses à dire et c'est ça qui est
très important c'est pour ça que ce club
n'est pas du tout partisan à politique
ça veut dire qu'ils ne prend pas part à
la politique
en fait dans le côté politique vous
pouvez retenir le côté noble du terme en
tout cas la définition étymologique
police qui veut dire est cité organisé
les politiques à ce qui veut dire
citoyens ensemble des citoyens
donc c'est vraiment ça l'idée c'est
c'est de constituer une espèce de vivier
d'idées de nouvelles propositions au
travers aussi de gens qui exercent voilà
dans différents domaines dans leur vie
merci d'être venu nous présenter ce que
notamment qui s'est montée du côté de
maurepas maurepas 2014 et cylia 2014 est
aussi même si le groupe est apolitique
parce qu'il ya des échéances absolument
pas ensuite il faudra aller voter vous
serez peut-être candidat en tout cas
vous n'avez pas fermé la porte a été
très clair sur ce point là pour la suite
on verra dans les prochains mois ce qui
se passera sur cette commune c'est la
fin de cette édition du 7 8
on se retrouve demain directes 18 heures
avec est de nouveau invité pour faire un
point sur l'actualité locale reviendront
notamment sur la grève qui concerne
l'ensemble des caisses d'allocations
familiales de france une grève pour
dénoncer la dégradation des conditions
de travail des agents demandé l'arrêt
également des suppressions de postes et
des embauches en cdi c'est une
intersyndicale qui est à l'origine de ce
mouvement à demain jeudi excellente
soirée prochain point sur l'information
sur tv fil 78 à 20h30 avec l'actu